[Music]
we all know and love the Disney classic
Pocahontas but the truth behind the
story is actually a lot more messed up
than anyone ever thought stay tuned to
find out why John Smith and Pocahontas
may have never actually been in love are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more great content
like this now onto the messed up real
story of Pocahontas the film was it just
us or was Pocahontas one of your
favorite Disney Princesses - she was a
total boss whereas most princesses are
kind of meek and gentle and do whatever
their fathers tell them in the film
Pocahontas was her own person she did
what she wanted and she never took no
for an answer
okay if you aren't familiar with the
film first of all what have you been
doing with your life with Lu be kind and
back up a little bit so the Disney film
centers around Pocahontas who is the
daughter of the chief of the PO Aten
tribe at the beginning of the movie our
favorite heroine learns that her father
wants to marry her off to kocoum who
seems nice and is super hot but
Pocahontas just doesn't love him during
all of this time the British settlers
come to Pocahontas his land John Smith
one of the settlers is less interested
in the gold that his crew came to find
and more interested about actually
exploring the new world while he is
exploring he meets and falls in love
with Pocahontas but their love affair is
pretty doomed because John tells his
leader that there is no gold in the land
and instead of backing off the leader
declares that they will wipe out all of
the natives seems reasonable right in
the midst of all this secret romance and
battling Thomas one of John's friends
ends up taking koklos life later John is
taken as Captain but instead of letting
him be hurt Pocahontas throws herself in
front of John and begs her father to
save him and not to start a war John is
spared but does end up getting the
gunshot wound and has to travel back to
England for treatment but before they
part
Pocahontas promises John that he will
always be in her heart so cute right
well it's all a bunch of make-believe
Pocahontas is the first Disney movie
that was created about a real-life
person except Disney didn't
they include many of the real details
their real story here's what really
happened
apparently Pocahontas his mother died
giving birth to her her birth name was
actually Metallica which means flower
between two streams and was probably
given to her because she was born
between the rivers of the maripony and
the Pamunkey after her mother died
Pocahontas his father was really sad and
Pocahontas became his favorite child
because she looked so much like her
mother she was raised by her aunts and
other women in their tribe during that
time it was customary for the paramount
chief to have other wives
so Pocahontas his dad had a few other
wives in other villages so the family
wasn't just Pocahontas and her dad liked
the movie made it seem here's where the
story starts to get creepy
according to her tribe history
Pocahontas was only about 10 years old
when John Smith and the colonists
arrived in 1607 John Smith was around 27
so if they did have something going on
it would have been absolutely disgusting
luckily they were actually never married
or even involved with one another the
children of Pocahontas his tribe were
all watched very carefully and because
she was a princess of sorts she was
probably watched even more closely and
provided with cultural training that the
other children did not get on the other
side in the movie we saw John Smith as
this guest guy who saw all men as equal
and was both equally kind and hot in
real life the native people stayed away
from him because he was known to go into
people's villages and put guns to their
heads and demand food and other supplies
in the winter John Smith
met with the patan warriors and ended up
being captured by the Chiefs brother
luckily for John the PO wattens agreed
with the English on one thing they both
feared being attacked by the Spanish so
they formed an alliance after a while
the tribe began to like John and offered
him a role as a leader and gave him a
better area to live in after many years
passed John said that Pocahontas saved
his life during the four-day process
where he was initiated into a leadership
position with the tribe but according to
written accounts from Pocahontas his
tribe why could have never happened
this is for a few reasons first the
tribe wouldn't have been trying to hurt
him if you
receiving such a big honor second
children weren't allowed in any of the
ritual ceremonies so Pocahontas wouldn't
have been allowed to be in attendance so
though the movie showed Pocahontas
selflessly throwing herself in front of
John Smith that never happened in real
life
Pocahontas also never actually defied
her dad to bring food to John Smith and
his crew in Jamestown why not well
because Jamestown was 12 miles from
where Pocahontas lived there's no way a
ten-year-old girl would have traveled
that far alone especially not a Chiefs
daughter if she did somehow manage to
escape her father and her people to head
to Jamestown she would have had to cross
several bodies of water that would have
required using one of the 400-pound
canoes that her tribe had there was no
way she could have lifted one of those
canoes into the water by herself so
Pocahontas actually didn't have much at
all to do with John Smith when she was
15 or 16 she actually did marry kocoum
had a child with him and moved to his
village soon a colonist named Samuel
Argyll went to look for Pocahontas in
order to capture her he demanded that
the tribe give her up or suffer an
attack she was forced to leave her child
in the village and go with Samuel though
she went as she was told
kocoum was still attacked after she left
later Pocahontas married Englishman John
Ralph and converted to Christianity some
say that she married him for love but
she was never allowed to see her family
again
so it doesn't sound like the
relationship was very mutually
beneficial John Ralph is mentioned in
the second Pro Cantus film and she does
go on to marry him in the movie but
Disney conveniently leaves out the
kidnapping and how the two ended up
meeting probably because no one would be
able to sleep through the night after
hearing the real story and that's it for
the messed up real story of Pocahontas
were you surprised by the difference in
the two stories let us know in the
comments thanks for watching
[Music]